في بلد يعاني من اسوا ازمه اقتصاديه جاء
الاول عالميا في الانفاق الفردي للسيجار
تقرير صادم اعتبره البعض محاكاه لتخدر
الشعب وتاقلمه مع الازمات لذا قررنا
الدخول الى محل احد مستوردي السيجار
للوقوف على حقيقه ما جاء في هذا التقرير
مختلف الاصناف معروضه وكانها تتباهى
بكماليتها تعرف انها مهما صعب امتلاكها
لاسعارها المرتفعه الا انها في لبنان
دائما تجد عشاق لها
هوايه هو شغف وهو كمان
الازمه الماليه عالميا السيجار كمان صار
يعتبر مثل الاستثمار يعني في مثل الساعات
مثل الذهب واي شيء ثاني كل واحد على حسب
حسب البادجيت تبعه وكل واحد حسب عيشته حسب
طريقه عيشته انا السيجاره عندي يعني انا
دخن سيجار يومي كل يوم احصاء نشره موقع
ستاتي افاد بان اللبنانيين يتفوقون على
الامريكيين البالغين من حيث الانفاق على
السيجار حيث جاء لبنان في المركز الاول
تليه امريكا ثم قطر نحن بلبنان كنا شهدنا
فتره من ال 21 22
بدنا نسميها هجمه بدنا نسميها سياحه
سيجاريه
كانت للتسوق السيجار كانوا يجوا من كل دول
العالم يشتروا من عنا سيجار وياخذوه لبرا
كان يجي ينباع بلبنان ويطلع لبرا اعاده
تصدير اعاده تصدير بس مش رسمه الرجي بيعه
بعشره مليون و700 الف دولار بالسنه بدنا
ناخذ هذا الرقم بيطلع عنا رقم كبير بينما
نحن اذا بنجي بندرس انه نحن بالتوانتي تو
كان الجمرك كان الجمرك على 1005 رغم هذا
التوضيح الا ان التقرير تحول الى ماده
سخريه بين اللبنانيين لبناني
الداين والزيان هون بالميه ثلاثه بالميه
اربعه اللي بيشرب سيجار الاغنياء وبيت
بابا بابا ما في حدا لبنان مدمر نهائيا
الاكيد ان لبنان يعيش انهيارًا غير مسبوق
لكن مواطنيه يحاولون بقدر استطاعتهم
الحفاظ على نمط العيش
ولو مع بعض المساومات نهد يوسف العربيه
بيروت
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات